es ist total beängstigend wer hier alles
auf die Insolvenz zu schlittert unsere
Krankenhäuser zum Beispiel haben gerade
ein echtes Problem erst die corona-krise
jetzt auch noch explodierende
Energiekosten die Deutsche
Krankenhausgesellschaft ruft ganz
offiziell die Alarmstufe Rot aus laut
einer aktuellen Umfrage der Deutschen
Krankenhausgesellschaft bei rund 270
Kliniken können 96% die aktuellen
Kostensteigerungen nicht selbst
finanzieren ja und das merken wenn es
blöd läuft irgendwann wahrscheinlich
auch die Patienten also jetzt nicht ich
aber die Kassenpatienten halt ne
Problem die Krankenhäuser können ihre
Mehrkosten nicht einfach an uns an die
Kunden weiterreichen da gibt es
schließlich feste Sätze wie Sie wissen
und das Energiesparpotenzial hält sich
bei denen in engen Grenzen aber mal im
Dunkeln operieren ist ja keine echte
Option
hoffe ich auch für das Sterilisieren von
OP-Besteck kommt man an Erdgas nicht
vorbei das wird mit so heißen Dampf
gemacht wenn okay mal am Ärmel
abschmieren kann man machen aber es kann
ja nicht die Regel werden 60% der
deutschen Kliniken schreiben schon tief
rote Zahlen ein einzelnes
Krankenhausbett verbraucht pro Jahr so
viel Energie wie ein komplettes
Einfamilienhaus und der Blackout hätte
da deutlich schlimmere Folgen wenn die
Klinik gar keinen Strom mehr hat dann
ist jeder sich selbst der nächste
stell dir das mal vor die Apokalypse
kommt und deine letzte Mahlzeit war
Krankenhaus Essen
Graubrot mit gesichtswurst
kann der Tod auch mehr Lösung sein
Deutschlands Krankenhäuser fordern einen
schnellen Inflationsausgleich durch den
Start sonst drohe Zitat flächendeckender
Personalabbau na das hört man doch gern
so zwischen zwei coronawellen für die
Kliniken kann der neue gasdeckel jetzt
gar nicht schnell genug kommen gibt man
Beispiel ein Haus mit 500 Betten zahlt
aktuell knapp eine Million Euro im Jahr
für Energie
ungedeckelt könnten das im nächsten Jahr
über 4 Millionen sein gleichzeitig
schlägt auch bei ja sagen wir mal
Verbandsmaterial Implantaten und
Skalpellen die Inflation zu alles wird
teurer aber können Krankenhäuser
überhaupt pleite gehen ja und zwar dank
der idiotischen Privatisierung unseres
Gesundheitswesens im Nachhinein wohl
eine lupenreine Scheiße Idee genau wie
die Einführung der Fallpauschale 2003
seitdem gilt der Patient nicht mehr als
leidender Mensch sondern als Rohstoff
für Investoren Idee bevor wir bald
Krankenhäuser retten könnten wir den
Bullshit rückgängig machen oder wer das
nicht in der Aufgabe für Karl Lauterbach
wo ist der eigentlich ja ist mein Gefühl
sieht man den selten in letzter Zeit
oder bilde ich mir das ein egal ich
wette jedenfalls der Minister hier ist
auch stinksauer auf die Leute die sich
damals die doofe Fallpauschale
ausgedacht haben die letzte wirklich
große
krankenhausreform liegt 20 Jahre zurück
die Einführung der Fallpauschalen an
dieser Einführung bin ich damals
beteiligt gewesen
ach so aber warum man weiß es nicht
meine Damen und Herren eine neue
krankenhausreform oder endlich eine
richtige Reform der Krankenkassen das
wäre meine schöne Aufgabe für unseren
Karl ernsthaft warum hört man nichts
relevantes von Lauterbach zu diesen
Themen dazu empfehle ich Ihnen das neue
Wimmelbuch wo ist Karl super wo steckt
da wo steckt der Racker ein Suchspaß für
große und Klein warte mal nein da ist er
nicht da auch nicht da bei Markus Lanz
er sitzt bei Lanz und redet über den
Corona Herbst ja hast du einfach viel zu
einfach
der corona-herbst heute übrigens auch
sein Thema in der Bundespressekonferenz
ohne Frage wichtig Corona aber es gibt
halt auch noch andere Gesundheitsthemen
wichtige seit der Einführung der
Fallpauschale geben in unseren Kliniken
in vielen Kliniken
Unternehmensberater den Ton an und die
sagen dann zum Beispiel bringt uns viel
mehr hüft-ops weil die Geld bringen das
geht so weit das geht so weit dass Ärzte
unter Druck gesetzt werden bestimmte
Zielvereinbarung einzuhalten kurz gesagt
wer besonders lukrative Behandlungen
verkauft wird mit Boni belohnt so wird
hierfür das Anwerben von über 190
Patienten mit einer bestimmten Krebsart
ein Bonus von 34.000 Euro versprochen
auch solche Vereinbarungen führen dazu
dass die Zahl der Operationen insgesamt
immer weiter steigt ja vielleicht können
wir auch so ein Bonussystem einführen
wenn man zwei Hüften kauft kriegt man
die dritte umsonst oder sowas
rund 40 Prozent der deutschen Kliniken
gehören inzwischen privaten Betreibern
oder Investoren oft auch aus dem Ausland
schön auf Effizienz gebürstet und
beraten von Firmen wie Porsche
Consulting ganz recht Porsche berät
Krankenhäuser dann sollte man aber auch
konsequent sein und die Darmspiegelung
umbenennen in abgasonderuntersuchung
oder
ich finde schon hier original Imagefilm
das Krankenhaus kann von Porsche viel
lernen was
Prozessoptimierungen angeht was
Umsetzungen angeht was Entwicklungen
angeht was Geschwindigkeit angeht von
der Idee letztlich bis hin zum Produkt
haben Sie das Produkt erkannt
bis hin zum produktpatient und wenn sie
zu Hause jetzt fragen was hat denn
Porsche mit Krankenhäusern zu tun ich
finde das passt schon denn die sorgen
schließlich regelmäßig für neue
Organspenden kurz gesagt kurz gesagt die
wahren Helden moderner Arztserien haben
oft gar nicht Medizin studiert freuen
Sie sich jetzt schon auf den neuen ARD
Vorabend
in aller Freundschaft die jungen
Controller
keine Sorge ihren Diabetiker Fuß werden
wir retten
oh Gott unser Börsenkurs fällt
[Musik]
Pflege Unterhalt bringt uns 3000 Euro
Amputation 10.000 Euro alles klar
gut dass ich so schnell reagiert haben
kein Ding das sind die Momente für die
ich BWL studiert habe neu in der ARD die
jungen Controller was für Arschlöcher
endlich meine realistische
Krankenhausserie
so meine Damen und Herren chill Reiners
ist Sprecher der profitorientierten
deutschen Kliniken Herr Reiners habe ich
das richtig verstanden auch die privaten
Betreiber möchten jetzt aber staatliche
Hilfe ja klar und ich weiß nicht wie es
Ihnen geht Herr welke aber ich möchte
nicht in einer Gesellschaft leben die
das helfen verlernt liebe Patienten
unterstützen auch Sie die kleine
börsennotierte Privatklinik in ihrer
Nachbarschaft auch sie können mithelfen
indem sie uns zum Beispiel nicht mehr
mit unrentablen Krankheiten belästigen
machen Sie mit bei unserer Aktion ein
Herz für herzklappt frage nicht was dein
Krankenhaus für dich tun kann sondern
was du für deinen Krankenhaus tun kannst
ja können wir die Musik bitte ausmachen
vielen Dank sie vertreten Unternehmen
hereiners die bis neulich zweistellige
Renditen eingefahren haben ja richtig
und das soll ja auch so bleiben
da hat sich doch eine schöne
Arbeitsteilung bewährt zwischen uns und
den gemeinnützigen Kliniken die
konzentrieren sich auf teuren nervigen
kramen wie auch keine Ahnung Kinder oder
Geburtsstation machst du nur Verlust
oder Krankheiten mit langen Liegezeiten
viele Patienten liegen rücksichtslos
wochenlang einfach nur rum
so lange wie manche liegen möchte ich
mal Urlaub haben
lachen ist gesund also das sollen die
mal machen und wir machen den Rest neue
Knie Schultern die geilen Sachen
schöne OP gerne wieder sagen wir da ja
nehmen wir mal Helios Deutschland
Deutschlands größter privater
Klinikbetreiber die haben in 2020 über
600 Millionen Euro gewinnen vor Steuern
gemacht nicht zuletzt dank der
großzügigen Corona freihaltepauschale
von Jens Spahn und trotzdem haben sie
letztes Jahr hunderte Stellen abgebaut
also welchen Teil des Wortes
gewinnorientiert haben Sie denn nicht
verstanden also manchmal wollen sie
vielleicht lieber zurück in die 70er
Jahre soll ich sie mal mitnehmen zurück
in die 70er absoluter Horror
[Musik]
wir haben ausgesehen wie komplette
Vollidioten und unser Gesundheitssystem
war quasi kommunistisch Krankenhäuser
durften in Deutschland keine Gewinn
machen ja sie wohnen halt ausschließlich
von öffentlichen und gemeinnützigen
Trägern betrieben ja ja aber man kann
das Wort gemeinnützig nicht ohne gemein
schreiben denken sie da mal drüber nach
wenn die in den 70ern Überschüsse
erwirtschaftet haben mussten sie die
Achtung zurückzahlen ich habe den
Begriff gegoogelt ich wusste gar nicht
was das sein soll der Staat steckt sich
die Kohle mit seinen kalten Griffeln
wieder in die Tasche und den Patienten
wurden überhaupt gar keine nutzlosen Ops
aufgeschwatzt wollen wir da wirklich
wieder hin in diese westdeutsche DDR
wollen wir das wollen wir das wirklich
wollen wir dahin zurück
eigentlich schon
Quatsch liebe Zuschauer jeder und jede
von ihnen ist heute gefragt um unsere
Rendite von morgen zu retten wenn bei
Ihnen zum Beispiel eine Geburt
bevorsteht dafür muss man nicht zwingend
ins Krankenhaus unsere Vorfahren ging
dafür einfach in den Wald
und alle Senioren und Senioren bitten
wir ganz herzlich fangen Sie noch heute
an mit Funsportarten wie Downhill
Mountainbiking
ohne Helm wir sehen uns chill Weihnachts
meine Damen und Herren
Audi Leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines Abo bitten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
na los
na los du scheiß Pferd hey